[Applause]
we don't ask for a lot here at tv sins i
mean if there's one thing people say
about us it's so we're super easy going
and consider it but do you really expect
us not to mention how unevenly you're
wearing these [ __ ] bracelets right
now this show makes it seem so easy to
make a glass sing like this but every
time i try to do it i just get wet
fingers why is [ __ ] so hard and it's
called [ __ ] right
glass holes also taking your love of
annie linux many many literal steps too
far i'll take it over previously on but
after this intro i'm seriously going to
struggle to concentrate on anything
other than ethan hawke's feet and i
already lose my thursdays to that i mean
he'd love to get out there but it's a
bit hard with one fin
yes because the world is rife with fully
finned fish jumping free of their
perspex prisons and living their best
lives for approximately 30 seconds until
they drown in oxygen still selling the
old brushes and brooms right
right in front of my entrance well yeah
because you refuse to acknowledge that
he also sells a single rake no wonder
the guy never leaves also let's go ahead
and address the dick van dyke shaped
elephant in the room that's oscar's
british accent sure it might be a
purposeful character thing but i've
heard some people say it's good and i've
heard some people say it's bad so i went
straight to my friend from england to
see what he thought and he said it's
rubbish that means trash in england ease
so how could i not sin it this student
treats a museum display as her own
personal rubbish bin and the only
consequence she faces for a pyramid
scheme is to be educated do you want in
title dance this is how you get entitled
ants if this is some weird audition to
tour guide here the answer is still no
right because who'd want a tour guide
that knows what they're talking about
tour guides just need to be able to know
how to point the way to the gift shop
and completely ignore my question about
if impressionists were sellouts because
they only did it for the monet everyone
knows this not telling the couple whose
picture you're talking about the
terrible backlighting problem in the
shot obviously can't have anchor
restraints on my bed can i
that's a definition of a red flag isn't
it i mean it's kind of a gray area
actually presumably the tape's there to
show if mark left his apartment in his
sleep but if sleep steven has the
awareness to unbolt the door and walk
somewhere wouldn't it be safe to assume
that he also has the awareness to
re-tape the door and replace any
displaced sand hello and welcome to
staying awake
let's start with trying to solve a
puzzle or let's start with not being in
the place where sleep happens surrender
the body to mark my name is not mark in
this scene
the idiot's in control the first
wednesday of november every four years
without fail don't just stand there run
midnight venom so hard that i'm have
expecting oscar isaac to find a lobster
tank to climb into any second now when
someone tells me they don't believe
we're living in a simulation i think i
should just tell them that both oscar
isaac and ethan hawk are in the same
marvel tv show there is not a believable
world where this seems possible so i'm
sending whoever wrote this simulation
for making it a little too obvious but
the scales see everything perhaps it's
something that lies ahead as the dead
for know its society here minority
reports this poor woman i have to ask
two questions first why would anyone
volunteer to do this when the outcome is
at best being told you have a good
person's face and the other choice is to
die on the spot for crimes you may not
have even committed yet and two how
great was that dead for knoweth society
joke i mean come on
dear god did he just turn that lady into
a raisin my childhood fear of the raisin
bran sun mascot turning people into
raisins is flooding back into my mind
two scoops do i have a meat
oh
pollux funny yes but what about the guy
who's still standing in stephen neal's
how do you know it wasn't him i'm trying
to get back home back to london
london if you were trying to find your
way home don't you think you'd be moving
away from the crowd or running down the
street to get yourself away from the bad
guys why are protagonists always drawn
to the danger plot magnets how do they
work so strange moon knight upgrades so
hard that i'm half expecting oscar isaac
to find a kitchen knife and bifurcate
someone's face with it beating six
people bloody in front of a child do you
think mark looked back at the kid and
said want to see something cool before
spiking the skull of a goon onto the
cobblestone right in front of her eyes i
mean if we're destroying innocence we
might as well be thorough geez marvel
you cut that action scene to death so
much that i have no clue what even
happened here oh god steven's immediate
reaction isn't core blimey guff what
happened to me old meat hook
what is his order of cupcakes doing in
the middle console of the truck you look
like you have plenty of room back there
which means the truck driver was
planning on eating an order ah
i knew it wasn't there some sort of
horror movie where there was this log
truck that resulted in a bunch of deaths
i can't remember what it was called but
i'm just saying this episode keeps
emulating movie after movie and i'm just
wondering what the final destination is
for all these rip-offs just a note on
human psychology if you were to pass out
and wake up driving a vehicle backward
you wouldn't have time to process that
consciously before your brain had
already instantly been overwhelmed and
shut down your motor functions my point
is this moment would not result in an
adjustment period it would result in a
steven is instantly dead and mangled at
the bottom of a ravine period
deus ex lagena stephen wakes up here and
is eventually relieved to learn it was
all a dream accepted wasn't a dream at
all so where did the injury on steven's
hand go and why isn't his jaw causing
him all sorts of michael caine
there's no way he spotted that fish was
a discount gus from that distance as it
was swimming around the tank you think
you can do these things but you just
can't stevo today what do you see i see
two fins yeah sorry show completely
ignores the caudal pictorial dorsal and
anal fins that's right goldfish have
anal fins
look as i said they've all got two fins
not finding nemo hunt peck phone control
for the love of efficiency people the
verizon gods gave you thumbs for a
reason use them i ate steak by myself
thanks two days ago if steven hasn't
been in touch with unnamed love interest
how did he even know where to go for the
date was best steakhouse in town really
enough to go on also does she not have
his number does he not have a single
voicemail or pissed off message from her
i'll put you for well done scene does
not contain a
what is with this accent right ironic
that being knighted makes you lose your
english accent
steven
stop looking i've put it off as long as
possible but this show is fresh
interesting quirky spooky and different
than anything the mcu has ever done and
i can feel my mirror mark taking over
just to take us in off stealing your
spooking techniques from library
haunting ghosts in the 80s for some
inexplicable reason steven chooses the
slowly descending metal box with only
one exit instead of the stairs as his
method of escape also i wouldn't take
this lift even if my life wasn't in
danger this thing looks like it hasn't
been touched by an engineer in decades
has witnessed multiple homicides and is
on the cdc shortlist of locations likely
to start the next pandemic oh my god
he's real why was he hanging out on the
same bus as steven he knows where steven
works so it's not like he needs to
follow him who takes the bus when they
don't even need to i'm just watching
lots of videos again wait is this all jb
does steven can't see his screen so
otter video seemed like a pretty wild
guess unless this is something jb is
famous for what's a big deal anyway
they're just furry little water oh look
at him cuddling his traffic cone
consider this had um had been free
she would have prevented hitler in the
destruction he wrote using her powers to
stop hitler cliche by even her own
avatar avatars blue people love that
film by avatar you mean that i mean
anime starting with the blue people
instead of the greatest show in the
history of nickelodeon i saw you kill
that woman in the alps it's been three
days and you still haven't reported this
to the law i mean not that the police in
this universe would believe a story of
discount kevin bacon turning people into
raisins somewhere in europe but it's
worth a try how exactly did he clear out
this entire room for this moment wasn't
this all taking place in the heart of
the day when the show needs it later
people will interrupt but the crowds are
being super polite now to avoid spoiling
the tension at the wrong time
[Music]
hello donna inspecting the weird noises
in your museum when you know where is
going down instead of getting the hell
out before the moon night at the
museuming can begin this metaphysical
egyptian demon ghost dog thing is toying
with stephen when in a few minutes he
will pounce the [ __ ] out of him why
this metaphysical egyptian demon ghost
dog thing is tricked by throwing a bag
so maybe it's just not all that smart
which makes it hard to care
episode does not contain a blip
reference for always in it marvel's
probably earned this 35 second
self-indulgent clip coffiny of logos the
problem is now everyone thinks they can
do it sega releases one halfway decent
video game franchise and it's like look
at our glorious undulating mountains of
ip slow your roll choo choo rocket no
one's here for you based on the last
episode steve's aware that he's getting
up somehow and going places even with
being chained to the bed so why is he
still bothering with it why are these
restraints yeah of course not show only
uses the mirror thing when it's
convenient for the plot also who has a
mirror on a wall with a door you have to
open to get to the mirror not saying
these types of mirror installments don't
exist but why why is this mirror do not
tell donna that i let you into
this arena you mean the arena that's
wide open to anyone who strolls by that
arena this is the surveillance
equivalent of having your password for
everything be the word password what
you're about to see
is gonna melt your brain no what's
melting my brain is that you never tell
him which camera or a specific time yet
he always finds the correct footage
clearly discount dax shepard is in on it
bruv it's like area 51 like
mi6 bonkers brother calling people bruv
also how's this like either of those
things steven mentioned steven was
chased by the ghost of an egyptian
jackal and gave himself over to the guy
living inside his head and turned into a
superhero shouldn't he say it's more
like a superhero thing or a shield thing
even if we find out this series doesn't
take place in the mcu proper they still
have [ __ ] comic books in this world
don't they i'm just saying area 51 and
mi6 don't cover these kinds of
predicaments watch here it comes suspect
asks someone to look at security video
to prove his or her innocence and it
ends up just making them look more
guilty cliche what are you doing you
donut thinking calling someone a tasty
and delicious treat is an insult am i
supposed to despise stephen i want to
eat him larry and maintenance is going
to absolutely
hilarion maintenance has a name ass hat
it's well it's larry i guess he did say
his name and i overreacted hmm this is
awkward look a cyclops desktop water
fountains it's the equivalent of having
an open container next to all the
equipment on your desk why would you do
that you you raspberry danish yeah so he
still doesn't work i know this is
classic hr to say but
you're not alone i know this is classic
tv since to say but this classic hr goes
on for all the some time this table's
had hands on it and mugs and pamphlets
slid across it yet somehow it looks as
if the glass is so clean that you can
see your reflection in it clearly enough
to ponder if your american doppelganger
personality might pop out for a bit to
say hi oh mate thank you oh thanks
cheers hugging discount shirley eaton
and making them break character when
their one job is to stay completely
still you can't go into someone's job
and destroy what they're known for come
on marvel do people come into your
environment and direct competent action
scenes i'm looking for my story soccer
it's under steve and grant it is not
understanding grant it might be on the
mark this works of course i know you
number 43 right and yet you let him him
and half for a full minute before saying
anything because apparently the show
still hasn't got enough of the oscar
isaac limey time yet
this is a terrible lighting system these
lights are apparently motion activated
extremely dim only stay on for a few
seconds while walking by and make an
extremely loud noise each time they turn
on or off it's almost like the system
was designed for maximum creepiness not
the ability to actually light a room and
now these metal walls are polished so
well they offer a perfect reflection
look around you right now how many
non-mirror crystal clear reflections of
yourself do you see if the answer's
north of zero my apologies you may
actually be a moon knight i'd say you're
a compass
you said holy [ __ ] nuggets this scarab
is magically floating wrong also what
about it's floating makes you think it's
a compass i mean it is a compass but i
think you only know that because you
read it in the script hello man in the
mirror
i was wondering if you'd pop up again
talking to the man in the mirror you
know maybe stephen will make a change
for once in his life my hair feels real
good you can make a difference you can
make it right look i don't care
how bloody handsome you are he looks
just like you he's more confident than
whatever this pommy needs his mommy
routine is sure but what a weird thing
to say to a person who looks exactly
like you look marvel i don't come to you
for genuinely creepy and vibey horror
thriller content i'm here for
superheroes cracking jokes and talking
about thanos so stop it with this
well-produced genre okay
freeze frames what is this moon knight
from the files of the police squad mark
where have you been conveniently falling
directly in front of your motorcycle so
we can move on to the next part of the
plot you feels like i'm riding with a
victorian duchess that's duchess did you
see the spiral you put me through i'd
give all the sins back if we find out
this movie's in the saw universe and
chris rock shows up to work out a
routine for his next gig at caroline's
stop with the accent please from your
lips to conscious ears layla she
shouldn't be here setting aside the
continued convenient reflection is
convenient bullsh steven isn't even over
here or likely visible in that tank's
reflection he's still by the door so can
the other personalities just appear at
random in any mirror anywhere now can
oscar isaac watch me in the shower no
seriously can he no no sorry i wasn't
talking to you but steven knows this is
how it'll come off right this is not the
first time he's been caught talking to
himself and he already knows she doesn't
believe any of his story about not being
mark no this is my mom's flat living in
your mom's flat as an adult and if you
think that's petty welcome to the
channel hope you stick around a while
occasionally there's a smell of cinnamon
buns it's a candle and not actually
cinnamon buns but it's still really nice
i promise she's my favorite part
um no she's my favorite geez guys more
than one person can love a thing i knew
toxic fandom started with marceline
disboard valmore i just knew it oh
nevertheless you just discovered you
were married to her steven i know you
were worried about the unilateral
comment being creepy but this is way
creepier for the record if mark is
really trying to get stephen to stop
showing her this stuff why is he doing
it from this tiny shaving mirror instead
of glorious fish tank reflection from
earlier and how does she even hear him i
need about 20 minutes of exposition on
all the rules of the mirror universe and
if you think it's too complicated feel
free to get margo robbie in a bubble
bath to explain it you're gonna get her
killed you hear me maybe start with that
line of approach next time mark and then
steven never even mentions the bag
because at this point she's gonna find
out what's in there for the sake of her
own curiosity you already don't remember
why we've been looking for this no but i
do remember for the last 10 minutes or
so layla's been insistent on how much
she doesn't believe steven's claims and
now all of a sudden for no reason she
does i vandalized the toilet referring
to the entirety of the restroom as the
toilet or just simply british people
let's just give two sins to make sure
we've covered all our bases what's this
it's paperweight i mean everything's a
paperweight if you try hard enough is
there any bigger symbol of our own
incessant need to commercialize
everything that we have a category of
items designed to hold down paper i
thought we were going to the police
station nope these two are with gatticas
vincent freeman who despite having
plentiful resources coming out of his
sarcophagus sack decided to wait 24
hours and then send a couple of lackeys
to pick him up instead of you know
grabbing him last night he was probably
stuck at the museum because he didn't
save anything for the uber back do you
hear me
i hear you loud and clear steven grant
of the gift shop that's a walkie-talkie
a walkie-talkie steven was not pressing
down on when he was talking to mark in
the rearview mirror so harrow shouldn't
have been able to hear anything steven
was saying episode doesn't know how to
walkie-talkie correctly let's get you
out of those cuffs that's nice and all
but our hero and his cult gonna tend to
steven's concussion as well that he
almost certainly got from hitting the
pavement when he fell out of that car
that's right that's why i'm here to help
oh i see we've reached the part in every
modern villain story where the villain
tries to convince the protagonist and
the audience that they're actually good
even though no one will buy it and they
will be proven to be a psychopath
shortly thereafter see this neighborhood
used to have the highest crime rate in
all the city
now
people don't lock their doors at night
they feel safe zentrification
oh
chase
are those the tomatoes over emphasizing
the when asking about the tomatoes
they're just tomatoes unless they give
you super strength or four hour erection
there's no need to emphasize anything
about them it's victor's recipe ignoring
the guard rails and sitting on a
crumbling artifice you're smarter than
that victor ahmed knows this too well
she tears evil up from the root casting
her judgment before any evil's done
minority report don't you do it do not
give lil up he's been sitting there by
this ultra reflective bowl this whole
time and you wait until harrow's done
his entire [ __ ] monologue to pipe in
having that much bread right next to you
and not eating any of it i don't care if
it's not vegan-friendly bread look at
how scrumptious it all is eat the bread
stephen he eat the [ __ ] bread
sometimes the cure
is a little
taste of the disease [ __ ] the cure
is the cure the cure is the solution the
cure is a new wave banned from west
sussex how do these idiots have these
terrible sayings ready to go at any
moment is there a villain soup for the
soul book i need to know about the child
is not a diseased limb
this is true disease limbs don't cry all
the time when they don't get their way
crash a car in a snowstorm because it
just had to have fruity pebbles or force
you to take out a second mortgage to get
them a four-year degree in philosophy
some people might even call a disease
limb a blessing in comparison do you
know what this is
yep
it's okay yeah stephen grant of the gift
shop would be the moon nightiest at tv
sins where's the scarab i haven't
what but why why is she here why would
she bring it even if she thought she
needed to save steven and did she track
his phone here did they let him keep it
and how did she get all the way in here
without being noticed or stopped or
frisked this entrance is dumb on a
motive level a practical level and a
character level also it's really nice we
have such a strong female co-lead in
this episode whose soul character trait
seems to be she's very convenient and
has great dramatic timing yay
moon knight i really do love the shows
using egyptian deities as the antagonist
but could we have gone with a look for
konchu that was slightly more commanding
than a scooby-doo villain some of the
suit roll communicates so then shackle's
been bumping into that door for the last
minute or so and it just opens now was
he messing with the doorknob knocking
gently building tension while stephen
once again makes the idiotic decision to
not give mark the body as it's written
into the script that's great that the
suit helped him survive this but what
helped him survive this from the moment
steven cliches his three-point landing
to the time the jackal jumps on him he
has a minute-long repartee with this
conveniently placed mirror mark was the
jackal just chilling up above waiting
for his cue i did it you got planted
scene of me finally getting my vegetable
garden under control somehow makes it
into the
episode do you reckon he's having a
seizure
look at him he's just a fancy drunk and
what city does being fancy included
latex white head and face covering this
the eyes wide shut universe please let
it be the eyes wide shut universe well
this whole rooftop chase is absolutely
badass i'm only human guys and honestly
i'm just glad the show has finally
decided to do some moon knighting but
also bruce willis and civil shepherd are
not making a tv show called moon
knighting in this scene
sorry we've always managed to keep a
wall between us but something's changed
i'm pretty sure the something that has
changed is that the story needs mark to
do some now pursuing seven years of bad
luck this aggressively
needing to see the pyramids this
aggressively then i i found him with the
scarab living 20 minutes from our old
place i'd give the show some props for
finding a new way to do exposition via
conversation with the local forger but
why would the forger need this info and
more importantly why would layla be
telling her wait they're going to have
the forger conveniently be a deep family
friend or some aren't they
also this shot making me momentarily
believe they were shooting this like an
episode of the office all of a sudden i
initially hated it then i loved it then
i hated it again that's why you look so
unhappy to be going home while her
relationship woes are likely a
contributing factor correlation does not
mean causation i'm just saying maybe she
doesn't want to go home because her
parents are constantly nagging her about
the amount of tv she watches and maybe
it's her job and not just a hobby and
maybe they should just get off my back
and let me follow my dreams
i mean her dreams ms forger's office is
littered with proof that it's a well
forger's office this 4g of evidence is a
great way to build atmosphere for a tv
show but maybe less great when you're an
actual forger who might want to keep a
low profile i don't
steal they've already been stolen got it
you're just like robin hood that was his
motto right steal from the rich and keep
it for yourself archaeology one big mess
of obsessive bookworms really according
to what i see in the movies and on tv
shows including this one archaeologists
are badass adventurers that'll kick all
the bad guy butt hell even alan grant
almost gutted an eight-year-old with a
raptor claw that one time the passport
goes in the machine one way in this shot
but comes out all turned around and
confused in this shot such experiences
should be reserved for freshman year of
high school and or the first time you
watch a film by david lynch apparently
egyptian passports do specify profession
and i'm just upset my government won't
officially recognize me as a pedantic
[ __ ] 30 seconds of this marvel
property slogo looking at this macguffin
and being confused it's literally
pointing you in the right direction no
interpretation is necessary also it's
not like they need to follow roads to
amit's tomb so why was scarab maps ever
pointing 90 degrees perpendicular to the
destination and yes this contradicts the
previous sin welcome to the channel i
have lots of questions about this
caravan if they're following ethan's
hawkeye why are they all spread out in
the distance instead of lined up behind
him how are these cars just now coming
up over this hill if they have cars and
communications then why didn't just a
few of them go on the trip and then
signal back after the bps does its magic
this unnaturally occurring trash hurdle
leaves a less cinematic but more
practical option tossing your knife in
the air so we know you're an [ __ ]
who's oddly prepared to start this fight
down a few fingers dancing we
you're fighting but one at a time and
never in a way that poses any real
threat to our protagonist also mark
would be the jets and the sharks at tv
sins
i don't know which one of my friends
needs to hear this but if i'm ever in
close quarters combat with another
individual please do not literally throw
a knife into the situation i lied i know
exactly which one of you needs to hear
this larry this knife flicking would
have been enough but considering he's
punched in the face mid-lick this means
he saw the punch coming but felt like it
was more important to finish licking
then protect his face
he must be a timex because it takes a
licking and keeps on um licking
and of course the blade is shiny and
clean enough for steven to make an
appearance i swear by this point you
might as well have him see steven in the
reflection of the enemy's eyes not only
is it just as ridiculous it has the
added benefit of being even less
thematically subtle mark's only a few
steps behind these guys when the shot
cuts then we see that he's climbed up to
the second story of a building for some
reason which was not helpful because
he's further away from catching them now
but it's still cool because he gets to
jump off this truck but whatever caused
him to take this alternate path was
probably cool as well and we don't get
to see it steven what did you do i swear
that wasn't me okay fine but you've been
in the knife reflection right you saw
what happened every other time you're in
some random reflection you seem to know
what's going on so why not this time and
honestly shouldn't both of you be in
there if there's a third moon child
then pull him back you script fulfilling
piece of plot tension if you had time to
say no kid in another second before he
cut the scarf with a knife you had time
to yank it there is always time to yank
it i didn't do any of this me neither so
neither of them was in control of their
body seems like an important and
concerning development but i guess mark
and steven have agreed to table that for
another episode keep digging
no matter what happens keep digging no
matter what what if they hit stone what
if they hit oil and up from the ground
come some bubble and crude what if you
tell them to stop digging what then mr
bossypants before a meeting of the anya
portal presents itself anywhere that's
why we named it the portal of ultimate
convenience aren't you coming with us
writers chose this cryptic non-answer
instead of i will suddenly and without
warning possess your body so stay loose
and don't eat any spicy food
we're inside title of my sex tape she
says it was not so long ago concho
enjoyed hathor's melodies hieroglyphs or
it didn't happen but manipulate the sky
again and we will imprison you in stone
this is a weird and oddly specific place
to draw the line so it's pretty wild
that this is the exact thing konchu does
later in the show we decided long ago we
did not wish to meddle in the affairs of
man not enough proof but i'm pretty sure
it's written somewhere that all new
marvel properties must include some
version of the prime directive as a way
of explaining where all the characters
that could have helped were during the
whole thanos debacle and i think it's
safe to say no one cares anymore let us
summon the accused i love how gods with
unimaginable powers still do old school
trials when they aren't blocking out the
sun or creating insta portals that know
exactly where the other avatars are i
shall smite the earth in the inhabitants
thereof and also if the prosecution
would call your first witness please
he's a deceiver
that's it that's the depth of conscious
argument when earlier he said our case
against hell must be indisputable i
thought we were about to see konchu go
full arthur kirkland from injustice for
all instead he went frito pandejo for
mediocracy i have no idea how many
personalities he must possess what does
that have to do with anything just
because kanchu's avatar has mental
health issues doesn't mean kanchu
himself is untrustworthy this is
secondhand ad hominem and i can't
believe the prosecuting attorney hasn't
objected yet he has committed no offense
this matter has concluded [ __ ] what
did you even look at any evidence do any
exploration of the facts this court of
the gods makes the u.s judicial system
look ultra competent in comparison and
that's quite a feat mark there is
another way of course there is i'm
looking for central sarcophagus see this
is the problem with the gig economy it's
not enough to just be a black market
information vendor you also need a side
hustle as a juice broker just to make
ends meet i hope you like attention i'm
not sure which is sillier that mark
would ask for sinfu's sarcophagus in
public or that layla just happens to
find him here did the fed write this
script because with every dumb or
convenient choice my interest rates are
certainly lowering i've never really
been able to just talk about
everything summon the skip preserving
history as a responsibility i take
various years almost as seriously as my
responsibility to install random mirror
pillars in my courtyard in case they
might be needed for any totally non-plot
related reasons
please just let steven out before you
blow this maybe a conversation you
should have settled before saying weird
things like this in front of your
already suspicious host you think also
i'm no expert in the preservation of
ancient artifacts but i learned a hard
lesson that one time i left my copy of
descent from xanadu out in the sun too
long so i'm pretty sure the open
sarcophagus of senpu it's not the type
of thing you store outside in a
transparent glass pyramid with
convenient ceiling mirrors especially
not in egypt
what
it's legit i don't care so much the name
dropping the student walk-in feels a bit
like an attempt to establish ancient
egyptian artifact street cred if there
is such a thing but i do care that the
show doesn't at least hint why this word
sounds german do you really think i'm an
idiot honestly no one knows what's going
on in the scene right now let alone what
you're thinking mark was holding pieces
of cloth he found in the sarcophagus
before you interrupted and we had no
idea where that was going so you're
holding all the cards and now would be a
great time to enlighten us it appears we
have a concerned third party yeah of
course we do is this show going for a
record number of scenes in which the
protagonists and antagonists meet in
don't actually confront each other do it
summon the suit conscious completely
making sense here but why does mark even
need to be told this if you had an
ass-kicking invincibility suit at your
beck and call aren't you calling that
[ __ ] down the second a gun appears what
just happened and how is that helpful
judging by the fact that this is what my
burrito looks like after putting it in
for 30 minutes instead of three i'm
gonna assume he just microwaved the
sarcophagus to destroy the star map but
if that was the plan he did a terrible
job at it since they're able to tape it
back together later why is scene sure
summon the suit now after arthur has
gone away show can kiss my full moon
knight
okay that was cool buy me some time i
can do that sometime you're about to
fling the bullet stuck to your cape with
enough pinpoint accuracy to take out
eight hinge persons i think you can just
end this thing now and then layla can
take all the time she wants this scene
illustrates just how difficult it is to
land the double midair kick i applaud
the attempt but you missed that second
kick and you'll be penalized accordingly
give me the body mark equipped only with
overconfidence in his ability to handle
this life or death situation steven
interrupts another fight sequence i
think the goal here was comic relief but
i also think it's safe to say that no
one is laughing it's all just like chill
the f out and talk for a second
see the body
take the body
okay now i'm laughing
i've removed my protective face shroud
so you can see how seriously i'm calling
out your name don't worry i'll put it
back on here in a second when i start
fighting the guys who have all the
sudden pause for this intense moment
taping ancient cloth in the desert all
right go ahead you're in you really had
to rip the mirror off the vehicle walk
away from the light source and dump the
already tenuous tape into the sand
before doing this
this this was the thing they were having
such difficulty reassembling i've seen
children put more complicated puzzles
together well um
actually steven just uttered a literal
um actually and i'm pretty sure we've
got those trademarked by this point so
here's a sin and you'll be hearing from
our lawyers disney so unless we know
exactly what the sky looked like on that
date so the star map only worked on one
night why the [ __ ] would anyone make a
map that only works for one night i can
turn back the night sky how it will come
at a cost let me guess the cost will be
a way to conveniently create plot
tension and stakes for the rest of the
season maybe the invincible moon night
won't be able to moon night anymore am i
close do what i do but do it while
standing in front of me and not being
able to see me because i'm taller and it
will look more cinematic that way the
universe survives this so let me get
this straight the mere seconds that
konchu and konshu jr have been spinning
the night sky all the other avatars got
the message portaled here and got set up
for this imprisonment spell
this show continues to play glass sounds
with every step harrow takes but
shouldn't that glass be embedded in his
foot by this point or crushed to the
point of not making noise or does he
have to stop every couple of hours at a
glass station to fill up i've seen so
many previously ons now that i'm
genuinely starting to feel emotions like
rage and anger and you know how we
process emotions over here at tv sins
blip i mean good on the pyramid builders
for thinking about the future needs of a
tiny god funko pop collection in
minimalistically appealing oil lamp
cubicles can't believe we haven't
mentioned this already but opening
credits for moon night does not contain
a moon night the trek drove over the top
of the dune this close to leyla and mark
and didn't see them that's almost as
ridiculous as layla somehow spotting
ammunition in the back of the truck as
it speeds by at night
[Music]
but whatever you do make sure you do not
check inside the truck just around okay
there's no chance she went in there so
don't even bother
oh come on marvel it's not like anyone
believes you'd kill off your main
character with only a few episodes
remaining
a flare is essentially a stick of fire
and fire alone would not be enough to
set off this ammunition especially this
quickly and if the ammunition were this
readily flammable it shouldn't have been
left uncovered like this so sin either
way suckers
you guys made a deal
that he would just disappear from my
life i hadn't
hadn't disappeared from your life
already steven would be [ __ ] brutal
at tv sins ian survives this suit was
his best feature wasn't it judging a
mark by its cover these bullet holes in
the windshield do not match the pattern
of these bullet holes in the same
windshield this high and mighty goat
i guess believing anything that comes
out your mouth just shows what a plunker
i am steven's calling himself for
believing mark while simultaneously
being mark so now there are two bloggers
plonking themselves and what you don't
know is this is now evolved to what the
british call a union jack don't look it
up i've been in situations like this
before
so have i it's the same body isn't it
muscle memory in that steven is
expecting to i still know kung fu his
way through a small army of machine
gunning goons after only yesterday
objecting to even being part of any of
this you smell like him i'll take things
that sound romantic but are actually
pretty [ __ ] creepy for two cents
please you know down okay first
before i belay thank you what's belay i
still can't tell when you're joking or
not as a general rule of thumb anytime
you know that the person you are rock
climbing slash abseiling with is
currently presenting with a personality
that you've only just met and here on
the side of not kidding just to avoid
any unnecessary confusion or broken
limbs and such also what exactly is she
belaying when she gets down there unless
she's planning on immediately climbing
back out the belaying's done and it
certainly isn't for steven's benefit as
evidenced by his rather abrupt
belay-less landing also also if layla is
lacking this very basic concept i think
it's in steven's best interest to delay
the belay and say hey you okay before
repelling down and breaking all of the
legs but i'm likely belaboring the point
at this stage are you okay
he fell from a great height directly
down into a tomb he should not be aces
if they just sprang to life right now
and
asked me a riddle for passage i'd i'd be
thrilled i shot myself but i'd be
thrilled
steven continues to be a bloody joy to
him it was a dream
worth dying for
and he did blip it's amazed
it's amazing look let's leave the word
play to the self-professed expert shall
we toot and count moon knight this whole
structure
is a symbol [ __ ] you dude i'm not mine
for a second that he's already been able
to piece together an aerial view of the
caves just based on walking through them
for a few minutes there are six paths
six pass seems important when they begin
to lay out the whole horus's eye thing
but the symbol of the eye doesn't have
six intersecting paths so when they
decide on the tongue path how do they
confidently decipher which of the six
pass represents the tongue so what
you think it's a map i mean to be more
accurate this is a conveniently recalled
symbol suddenly drawn on a conveniently
reflective table that somehow very
quickly became a convenient map
hexahed car sorcerers of their time
fortunately for us steven's knowledge of
egyptology only stretches to the point
where we the audience need something
explaining hey
you go me yeah unnecessarily splitting
the party i guess i've never come across
an ominous gaping cavern before but if i
did and i were being chased by an undead
murder mummy would i stop to investigate
the depths of the pit with a flare no no
no i would sh myself while navigating
the fastest route out
yes because the first thing you do after
realizing the holes in the wall allow
dead arms to jut through is to turn your
back on the wall with the holes you know
the momentum should have carried her to
the bottom of the pit i know the
momentum should have carried her to the
bottom of the pit but someone on the
writing team forgot also at some point
these oh no they died fake outs are
resolved so quickly you're left
wondering why bother no one believes she
actually fell to her death here and even
if we did we're only allowed to sit with
that suspense for like eight seconds oh
you kissed her this is what is important
to mark right now everyone's in danger
and he's feeling the need to start a
pissing contest with himself i think
we're looking
at the long lost tomb
[Music]
of alexander the great oh
huh so why don't you just
go ahead good thing both these two came
miced up so they could hear each other
speaking very softly across this not in
substantial distance floor is yours the
floor may be harrows but the walls are
the mummy killer's walls so stop leaning
on it everything inside me is like
screaming not to open this thing
everything apart from the only actual
voice inside him which is ironically
telling him to open it this symbol of a
waiter serving a piping hot plate of
three flaming hot dogs so what do you
think i think it's super convenient that
alexander was great enough to line his
loot in shiny reflective material that
allowed this reflective conversation to
continue sir
we just found another way harold and his
goons had a huge head start over steven
and layla and yet they still managed to
find amit's tomb last he should have
been able to swarm through this place
just through sheer numbers alone the
scare pointed directly down to ahmet's
tomb so why would it point to the
entrance and not over the actual
location of amitsuhapti seems like
there's a nice opening that leads
outside right here so ride that shaft
all the way down to the good stuff man
i'm talking to mark
well that was easy for once but why how
did he die unless this conversation
leads to the revelation that on the
night of her father's death mark also
found a secret exit out of the lost tomb
of alexander the great can we please put
a pin in it until after they've escaped
the angry men with the guns come on
bringing a ceremonial axe thing to a
gunfight
oof we're still bringing your chest to a
gunfight
oh come on marvel it's not like anyone
believes you'd actually kill off your
main character with only a few episodes
remaining it's pretty clear from this
angle that mark's falling down a flight
of stairs before hitting the water but
then he doesn't i can't save anyone who
won't save themselves but he doesn't
care about redemption or second chances
his whole deal is stopping people before
they even have a chance to redeem
themselves or before they even realize
they have something that requires
redemption you're dr stephen grant maybe
so you've got plunk imagine getting the
call from marvel that your cast is
steven grant and moon knight and it's
this role instead of what we've been
seeing the past three episodes this is
beautiful
very impressive o
m
g
what is up with the ratio of icing to
sponge on this cupcake i took the
liberty of borrowing the film you
brought my actual sex tape how many
times did you say you've seen that movie
despite all parental warnings enough
times to make him go blind apparently
this moment between harrow and his
assistants carries on for us after mark
runs away if this is all in mark's head
why would anything outside of mark's
perspective persist just in case they
never answer this question i'm going to
send it now and ask for forgiveness
later whatever [ __ ] the sarcophagus
says that may or may not be important
but i don't have time to crack the code
[Applause]
i'm not sure what the [ __ ] is going on
but this moment clearly represents a
person trying to find what makes them
whole i didn't realize how badly i
needed these two characters to be in the
same physical space and the relief on
steven and mark's faces as they embrace
is something i felt in my soul if i had
one i mean how is this possible i don't
know me either but someone left their
thermos mug and useless lamp here on the
shelf pointing like this must take too
much effort stop it mark just found
steven in a sarcophagus and it was a
pretty great reunion why would he pass
up another one is it because the third
personality inside isn't crying for help
and no the third personality isn't a
spoiler there have been several hints so
far in this upright creepy red container
is confirming all my suspicions anyway a
cent for not opening the obvious reveal
when it is obvious
[Music]
mark and steven do not actually shoot
themselves in this scene also marvel did
not release all six episodes at once
forcing me to spend far too much time in
the deep dark holes of the egyptian lady
hippo subreddits also also holy [ __ ]
after that subreddit dive marvel may
have actually killed off a character
with only a few episodes remaining i'll
give one of the sins back just in case
they have the balls to stick to it he's
tethered to this place but not the
actual place right the ashanti can leave
the pyramid and still serve its
prisonery function as we saw last
episode and right here on the previously
awnings opening an episode on falling
water now i just have to pee moon knight
is an out of nowhere need to urinate
really how you want to start your
episode is it this is oh
episode and really the series as a whole
deals with abuse on a level i rarely see
in a streaming franchise meant for the
masses especially ones revolving around
superheroes that also poses a problem
sometimes since there's a lot of cutting
between biting moments such as this and
pow-powing the bad guys straight-up
murder or in this case screaming
egyptian deities that look like hippos
however even if moon knight doesn't
always land the thematic punch i like
how hard it's trying that's worth a sin
off your mind is violently vacillating
between sense and nonsense an accurate
description of me trying to make sense
of this plot speaking of violent
vacillation this scene cuts to a wide
shot and a close-up shot back and forth
10 times stop it you're not really a
doctor and you're really not mark or
steven are you huh strange third man
with a broken nose okay yes maybe i saw
a few spoilers before watching this
episode and it may be playing up that
the visualization could or could not be
mark's other super dangerous personality
i i feel real i feel like a real doctor
and i'll see a bullet suckers on your
desk that mark can choose from after he
proves to be a good patient so how real
of a doctor could you really be hero
what i find extremely interesting
is this new um
the new animal character what i find
extremely interesting is how harrow has
a functioning backside with a terrible
posture i mean look at the way you slim
down in that chair you think you could
tell me about that little boy gird your
emotional loins folks moon knight is
about to hard shift out of egyptian
deity shenanigans and plow right into
the depths of a tragic backstory
involving way more than i thought i was
gonna get into and yeah yeah i know i
said the thing earlier about it being
interesting how the show handled the
subject of abuse but like mark i'm a
complicated being is he always so
intense both mark and stephen were
freaking out as they should be when
confronted with a talking hungry hungry
hippo so why is to wear it singling out
mark so are you two like twins why is
the goddess of whatever confused by this
wouldn't she be able to sense if this
were two people it's been a minute since
we've had a soul passed in here oh so
now they're a soul and clearly not twins
but also why has it been long enough
that she's forgotten her whatever scroll
i know i read about her but none of that
really helped much for this moment
welcome
gentle traveler
travelers i'm not being welcomed by a
walking and talking hippopotamus in this
scene or i'm not on the drugs that would
allow me to see a walking and talking
hippopotamus i just want to have a
conversation with the walking and
talking hippopotamus is that too much to
ask gerard the egyptian underworld and
playing the part of explainer of words
is once again drumroll please you'll
never guess it steven what is this
unseen footage from pirates of the
caribbean i'm not crazy
i'm dead being this thankful that you're
dead it was little old me worrying i'd
blow your chest wide open why was she
worried about this i don't know how the
egyptian underworld rotation shifts work
but i'm willing about all my sins that
tewer has had to do this before this
can't be her first underworld rodeo a
couple of questions first if they're
treating mark and steven as if they're
two separate entities then why doesn't
each heart get to be weighed by itself
when harrow was [ __ ] around with his
staff in earlier episodes that was just
one person at a time in second if steven
is just part of mark and not an actual
person then how does he have an actual
heart i get that we are not supposed to
know steven is a personality mark
created when he was younger but the
egyptian underworld should know this
they're gods why would a god need a
scale of justice oh sorry star trek five
there for a second at least i didn't
fully star trek five you never want to
fully star direct five
no one balance souls on my boat them's
the rules are you sure about that to
wear it because as confused as you've
been this whole time i have about as
much faith in your knowledge of the
egyptian underworld as i do of tvson's
knowledge of mature discourse and
restraint
i do not have a card for this it's the
hearts it was like i don't know what's
happening to let's go with your hearts
need help in zero seconds flat also i'm
pretty sure you do have a card for this
to wear it you said if the hearts don't
balance with the feather then mark and
steven are thrown overboard they're not
balancing so that should be it but mark
and steven will get a chance to make
them balance because
reasons it's like they each feel
incomplete the hearts are incomplete
because the multiple personalities
aren't united but the show never
addresses how any of the sudden
balancing works when there's an entire
third personality no one's even talking
about
that's wild
that's a previously on during the show
and you cannot fool me just a creepy
calf filled with dead bodies shortening
the word cafe to calf also for all of
you who think the walking dead's biggest
issue is that it's boring moon knight
gives you an alternative with the
sitting dead and honestly feels about
the same dubai
no mark dubai is the most populous city
in the united arab emirates that is a
person this is all
your fault i would hope that all the
adults in this room realized that the
mother needed some help to process the
grief of her dead son but nope the show
wanted us to know that this entire
situation is a massive [ __ ] to mark
so it placed a massive bowl of apples on
the table
before they were having to walk down the
hallway and open doors to get to each
memory but now mark can just tackle
stephen into another memory and blah
blah blah these are memories none of
this is real etc but the episode sets up
some pretty clear guidelines on how mark
and stephen can navigate this terrain
and then just throws it out the window
when it needs to i am the god
i know mark is dealing with a lot of
stuff at this moment but i still want to
point out that he accepts this is an
actual egyptian god talking to him way
too quickly you
are a worthy candidate to serve me
during this time kanji was really
starting to feel like a discount jigsaw
the more we learn about his origins with
mark do you swear to protect the
travelers of the night kanji says
travelers and not shadows but i'm still
going to issue a scene does not contain
allison pills singing pat benatar sin
because honestly now that star trek
picard has put that in our lives really
should be in every tv show for all the
rest of time also what does that mean
exactly are people only eligible for
protection while traveling and only at
night why is there never any time to
talk about the fine print
rise and live again
as my fist of vengeance
as my
moon night roll series commercials
balance there's a lot of interesting
subject matter being addressed in this
episode and there are a lot of fun
egyptian underworld shenanigans as well
however this scale's balancing mcguffin
that takes up too much of the running
time never makes a lot of sense and only
leads to a death that is not really a
death which was already a death that
wasn't really a death i'm so tired you
watch too many movies all right wrong
channel hero i watch too many tv shows
tv shows letting your child be a chicago
cubs fan potty hell
look at the state of this place this
show can try to rationalize steven's
terrible accent all at once but it's
still a terrible accent that we have to
listen to for five episodes and counting
so you're still getting a sin moon
knight well this time i thought i was
the original wait did people really
think there was a chance steven was the
original was this supposed to be some
sort of twist but you've gotten to live
thinking that she loved you that she was
kind that she's still alive trying to
write my head around the logistics for
all of this to unfold is making me feel
like i've lost my mind so steven is a
personality that mark created to escape
his horrible abusive life and at some
point after mark became moon knight the
steven personality was able to take
control for the majority of the time
fine but he was able to get a job in an
apartment is stephen how did he even
have the correct paperwork and
identification for stephen grant to get
all these things accomplished steven
grant doesn't exist and doesn't have a
social security number how would any of
this work she's in life i speak to her
every day so it's not just that mark
made stephen but steven is also mentally
designed to never experience confusion
about why someone doesn't talk back to
them on the phone got it i'll just file
this with things that the mind can do
that are scary as f which is right
beside things a show won't explore more
in order to avoid having to explain
itself a little haircut
little silly tash there
it's very
ned flanders we get it disney you own
the simpsons now we're all so proud
it didn't know you smashed it on the
ground a moment ago you don't have to
say you're sorry to the hat holy crap
they killed stevie i didn't expect that
glad the show will continue to honor the
beauty of these big moments and won't
immediately bring steven back in the
very next episode can you
imagine ah
scales are balanced so only one of at
least three personalities had to die for
the scales to balance that checks out i
guess also the afterlife is addictive
people with weed allergies i've got it
the previous leons will stop once
marvel's wasted a collective five years
of my life giving me a greater
appreciation for those who lived through
the blip oh [ __ ] that takes us up to the
year 2364.
why do tv shows think that showing a
character hearing a suspicious noise but
choosing to dismiss it is any less
ridiculous than the character just not
hearing said noise so he gets to turn
his cane into an axe staff just for
finding amit's game piece show us some
weird level ups lelax like this is some
kind of burial at sea and that she
doesn't just submerge him in the scummy
surface runoff that's found its way into
this ancient egyptian tomb also layla's
seen some pretty crazy [ __ ] at this
point so wouldn't she at least think
about preserving mark's body knowing the
shenanigans konchu might be able to pull
to revive him it's pretty stupid to
leave behind the one thing that could
potentially lead someone back to
dushopti in arthur's possession it's an
entire distinct pantheon of stupidity
unto itself to leave said thing with
someone who has already been returned
from the brink of death once before
while said person's companion is still
at large of course the above is made
totally mood because layla doesn't even
use the damn thing to track harrow she
just follows them out of the damn tomb
and gets into the car with them how do
checkpoints even work on this road
people seem to be traversing this
territory in every which way they please
come to think of it why did they
approach the checkpoint at all instead
of just continuing on through this
well-traveled desert you need to show us
your soul the righteous ray of reckoning
was omnidirectional so why didn't it
cast its periwinkle wave over layla
purple purple purple purple staff brown
suit judging all the people rolled up at
the checkpoint judging judging all the
people people falling around the people
stealing purple from the people people
falling around the people cause my evil
purple steeple people this is the face
of a good man said without seeing his
face you don't need this anymore hey
that's my line don't do it
leila wait i am the goddess to wet it
yeah never mind that's not weird at all
and in no way worthy of anything more
than a slight sideways glance onwards
well i was standing right there in the
middle of these [ __ ] and no one even
notices there may be good people
according to ahmed but i'm wondering if
a more strict criteria should be
followed in terms of recruitment maybe
more of a focus on situational awareness
does this staff come with a [ __ ]
instruction manual how does hero know
this will open up the pyramid why
haro that's your who not your why this
doesn't need to happen yes please
immediately cut away from the epic
battle of the gods i'm sure this
showdown will hold absolutely zero
interest for any of us you rotten [ __ ]
teases this is all so avoidable indeed
all the confusing character motivations
were avoidable and i'm happy you've come
around to my point of view all the
avatars die and since the only one we
hear from is towerette we must assume
that the rest of the gods were like oh
well you win some you lose some really
undercuts how important any of this is
it makes you wonder why amin and kanchu
are so invested so to trap these scouts
in these statues it takes a ceremony
with five avatars casting a spell while
holding hands but to release them from
the statue you just spike it on the
ground in the end zone well so i'm
pretty sure we're supposed to infer that
the ushabti has to be smashed inside
this specific end zone in order to free
the kinder surprise inside if not why
wouldn't harrow have destroyed it as
soon as he got his hands on it and if so
why aren't these pesky gods imprisoned
in the uchoptia and then yielded outside
so there's zero chance of exactly this
situation ever happening why keep them
in the one place they can be freed by a
passing breeze your
kind
scales
lack
big thing to say to the person that just
freed you imagine if the first thing
your boss said to you when they got back
from vacation was you suck and you're a
bad person they lack balance because of
what lies ahead of you what lies ahead
of you is your service to me now imagine
if your boss said you suck and you're a
bad person because you work for me also
this might be a weird question but i'm
beginning to wonder if anyone bothered
to check if the scales have been
properly calibrated because you won't
win against heroin army alone
i'll take my chances i understand not
wanting to work with khanshu but the
alternative is taking your chances
fighting a god all alone with only your
unfounded optimism at your side
time has been cruel to you i'd say he's
a [ __ ] skeleton but the writer should
know that when i point these things out
you get one sin and when you point them
out but don't provide an explanation you
get three sins now my call i'm only a
humble avatar for cindy the goddess of
snark and protector of the tv syntheon
leave here and you can't return show
thinks this is an ultimate sacrifice but
they've been breaking more rules in the
afterlife than bill and ted so i'm
pretty sure mark just figures there's
probably a workaround so i get to go on
to eternal peace before you get too
excited about eternal peace think
carefully about wandering around this
wheat
you saved me blip
i'm throwing this down yeah but why did
your leg fall asleep you were frozen for
way less time than steven so i don't
think you should be taking this long to
thaw because this is marvel of course no
one's powers are explained or quantified
but i think it's safe to say these two
gods should have more in their arsenal
to try before having to resort to
bashing into one another i choose
obliteration over mercy other than
ghosting yourself out of this place
which is exactly what he does when he
realizes mark is back was that not
always an option i kind of remember
removing sins for marvel being brave
enough to kill off a main character and
then something about promising to resend
them if they didn't follow through i
apologize if all that feels a bit
inconsistent but if the show is going to
be vague with what is and isn't reality
i'm going to be vague with what is and
isn't cynical how's this deal going to
work
you would negotiate now
with so much at stake conscious would be
amun raw at tv sins
i will release you both you'll have my
word i'm sure the show would never rely
on subtle distinctions in language to
allow kanchu to keep his word and for
the moon nighting to continue sure that
would never happen now how the heck are
we gonna get to cairo you forget little
world
i am still the blonde of the night sky
yes but how does that work in the middle
of the day he's either accelerating the
rotation of the earth to make it night
prematurely or he's accelerating the
passage of time itself either would seem
to be get some unintended side effects
we need to imprison on it in a mortal
form nobody instead of a statue if a
person is being used as a vessel similar
to a statue how does this make amit more
vulnerable to get out ahmet should just
have to break the person like they broke
the statue maybe not just like the
statue it'd be pretty hard to spike a
person into the ground with that much
force we need more avatars
than we have
my dm to james cameron somehow makes its
way into this episode ahmet starts
sucking up all these souls and grows
super tall which i thought was weird on
its own but then konchu does the same
thing after eating zero souls so now we
have no idea if the soul munching was
necessary or all for show i'm gonna go
with yes i'm sending the needlessly
aggressive deployment of this wing sword
combination as a potential hazard and
public nuisance
falcon in the lunar soldier
this is a great moment for
representation so i'm taking a sin off
for the kid out there that feels in this
moment included in the cultural
phenomenon that is the superhero genre
but this kid also stayed in harm's way
to ask this question and that's not the
type of curiosity we want to encourage
this is the equivalent of trapping a few
feathers it's not even the meat of the
wing i mean her arm basically scarlet
scarab can't wriggle out of this one
because plot the fight between kanchu
and ahmet seems mostly inconsequential
the literal god fight takes a backseat
to the avatars and while it's nice to
see that marvel is more aware of the
inherent problems here than dc the story
seems to be trying to ignore it
okay buddy make sure you really test the
bulletproof nature of that wing before
trying her legs hands or any other
exposed body parts yeah show subverts
the whole how's he gonna get out of this
one by not showing it at all and asking
us to just assume that whatever happened
was cool for the millionth time what the
hell was that the viewer's reaction to
this scene somehow makes its way into
the episode muhammad is dragging away
what looks like an unconscious consu
unconscious shoe but how does that even
happen can gods be knocked unconscious i
suppose this could all just be a
metaphysical battle being presented to
human eyes in a way that can be easily
comprehended but why
that haro
i know how to stop ahmed i probably
wouldn't bother layla judging by the way
harrow's neck stays perfectly straight
as mark lifts him i'm fairly certain
rigor mortis is already set in yeah i
don't
don't think you know as much as you
think you do who me oh no i know exactly
what's going on i have a firm grasp on
what's real and what's actually just in
mark steven or mystery player number
three's head i mean i could totally
explain it to you but it'd take far too
long really and i wouldn't want to bore
you here's what we'll do when when you
figure it out come back and tell me and
willem compare notes you know just so
that i know that you know and will be
avoiding spoiling anything you didn't
realize you didn't know you know we'd
rather go save the world saying this
after you've decided to no longer be the
moon knight is like taking your
glass-filled shoes off after you've
already suffered massive blood loss meet
my friend
jake lockley
show does not end with a moon knight
will return leaving me with so many
unanswered questions why are mark and
steven unaware of oscar the grouch is he
another coping mechanism created by mark
if so why is he speaking italian why did
the egyptian gods intervene with ahmet's
plans but not thanos and when will we
see the glorious hippo lady again
[Music]
serving ahmed is tough business long
nights strange hours and even stranger
places if you told me one day i'd be
snatching souls straight out of people's
bodies i'd have had a good chuckle but
that's the thing about life sometimes it
takes you down the road less traveled
and sometimes it takes you off the road
completely and when i go off-road i
always depend on my ford raptor built to
survive the wrath of the gods built for
come tough play with us danny and i'm
gonna keep doing a boat because they
make me feel good it's not like there's
anything in there the [ __ ] you say to me
a little
i've been good
my entire life but you crazy ass [ __ ]
london
don't know what i'm saying like that you
sound like you're from london
that's so strange sorry
the pen
that i hold in my hand
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
don't get the monkeys take this
downstairs can't be bothered you're not
worth the trouble it would take to hit
you
donna
i'm the captain now
stupid dog you made me look bad i'm
standing here you make a move
you make a move
it's your move
are you crying why are you crying
there's no crying
how long are my weight in
different angle yeah
different
you look a little nervous
first time holding a gun hello man in
the mirror this was your idea george
it's a good idea right it's a good idea
monogamy is sexual slavery
tell me what it is you are
what are you
you sure you want to know yes study yes
i'm batman you want my body
right yeah mark how about this for a
deal you've got the body
i've got the brain
it's not okay yeah i'm still your wife
uh my wife stop with the accent please
that's how i
a bit dodgy like trusting the judgment
of a weird crocodile lady strange women
lying in ponds distributing swords
there's no basis for a system of
government
i've already got my name picked out
lord rupert everton i'm a uh
a shipping merchant who raises fancy
dogs no he's uh he's probably going to
get himself killed running around cairo
what is the five fingers side of the
face
what
oh my cabbages
so
what about the other gods are they just
gonna stand by and allow somebody to
unleash ahmed they know
they just don't care
keep digging
no matter what happened
i must admit i do not miss the sound of
that voice
but speak old master to the point and
the truth
shall set you free
this is not about my feelings i'm not
the one on trial here you're out of
order you're out of order the whole
trial is out of order he's gonna kill
millions trust me are you seriously
talking about truth
humanity's savage nature will inevitably
lead to global annihilation
so in order to save this planet
i had to trick it
for the greatest practical joke
in human history
[Music]
[Applause]
stephen
wake up
come on
i strongly suggest
that you wake the [ __ ] up
you're only supposed to blow the bloody
doors off we were somewhere around
barcelo on the edge of the desert
when the drugs began to take hold
you guys made a deal
that he would just disappear from my
life i hadn't
they disappeared from your life already
emotional damage you're in love now
you're in love with my wife this is my
wife
i shall call him squishy and he shall be
mine and he shall be my squishy
i like swimming but i'm dangerous
frank you think
god stays in heaven because he too lives
in fear of what he's created
picture this i'm a bag of dicks put me
to your lips you're really good i was
down and i emailed you
and i woke up and i feel better i i i
feel better so are you two like twins
and twins
we're not going to feel the reeds either
all right what are you proposing
you're going to need a bigger boat
i'm batman
you
are a worthy candidate to serve me
during this time
[Music]
phenomenal cosmic powers
where we're going we don't need
roads
you don't need to see his identification
we don't need to see his identification
these aren't the droids you're looking
for
you
shall not pass
open sesame
you don't need him anymore mark i need
my right hand man back
[Music]
new teeth that's weird so where was i
[Music]
oh no
[ __ ] steps on a church in my
town
heat em up
let's show this prehistoric [ __ ] how we
do things downtown
i'm really jazzed about showing you
these new skill sets we have
show me what you got